a partir del fin de la guerra de nagorno
vara para garbiñe se encuentra sumida en
una profunda crisis política marcada por
las movilizaciones de la oposición y los
ciudadanos descontentos que exigen la
renuncia del primer ministro niccoló
para chillán y lo acusan de poner en
riesgo la seguridad nacional y la
integridad territorial de su país hoy el
gobierno anunció la destitución del jefe
de estado mayor de las fuerzas armadas
únicas varian manifestando que debido a
que el presidente no firmó en el tiempo
establecido
el proyecto sobre su despido presentado
por el primer ministro ni tampoco lo
presentó ante el tribunal constitucional
legalmente o ni kasparian debe dejar de
ejercer sus funciones en las fuerzas
armadas a partir de hoy por su parte
gaspar ian emitió un comunicado en el
cual reafirmó que esta medida no es
constitucional y también recurrió al
tribunal administrativo a los fines de
garantizar
la supremacía de la ley el resto de las
autoridades militares apoyaron este
mensaje del jefe de estado mayor de las
fuerzas armadas aunque el gobierno ya
nombró a su sucesor art acta de tian
para que ocupe este cargo mientras tanto
continúan las movilizaciones por parte
de la oposición encabezadas por el
movimiento de salvación de la patria en
la sede de la asamblea nacional de
yereván
[Música]